nearly a hundred street lights are out
all across the valley because the copper
wire was ripped right out of them the
county now sending crews out to handle
the repairs but the metal is being
stolen from more than just the lights
madison kimbrough live in the newsroom
with more on another incident that cost
one business big yeah copper a hot
commodity these days with it selling for
close to four dollars per pound and from
city street lights to air conditioning
units like the ones you're about to see
these thieves are taking advantage in
order to make cash fast
public work crews hard at work repairing
county street lights this particular one
off of highland drive and polaris the
county says the outages are the result
of copper wire theft thieves are
stealing and selling the metal for high
profits to recyclers las vegas business
owner scott fywell says just a couple
months ago his roof along with his
neighbors was raided resulting in
massive damage and costly repairs we
walked up to the roof and just to see
what was going on and see what was wrong
with the units and we noticed that all
of the copper was stripped from the
condenser units they stripped 15 of
their units as well
all of the copper all of the copper
aluminum and all of the wiring in there
got stripped next door
two hundred thousand dollars and it
wasn't covered by insurance because that
building wasn't occupied fivewell says
they have since moved their ac units
into an indoor back hallway and haven't
had any issues but says as long as the
scrap yards are buying there are going
to be those who take advantage stating
that the background check when it comes
to selling these items isn't extensive
there's no markings on it i think
generally at the scrap yards they
require people to give their name show
id and finger or thumb print but these
components aren't components that have
numbers on them that you can track
so there's not much that can be done
about it
and the county wanting locals to report
any streetlights they see out to fix it
clark county we have that link attached
to this story up on our website in the
newsroom madison kimbrough live local
now